Hausa go rats bunnies welcome back to
another episode of egg to dead let's get
it on baby so fabulous no efficient when
they see one
oh no oh we're basically fired honey are
you alright
what has got you so spooked okay I'll
just have to add that to the list of
questions don't worry we're here for you
now let's get some tickets
it's kind of a [ __ ] like if she knows I
don't want to go to the aquarium why
does she have to force me kelp that
sounds fun GK something smells fishy
I'll always say that okay they know a
fish when they see one so keep out of
their sight well when the earth was
that's exactly what that boots I'm
setting in line is for [ __ ]
what up what up it's my turn ice I
waited there you go
scan this [ __ ] no thank you hey what
are you doing what are you doing hi hi I
oh I oh I oh I oh you want to fight me
you want to fight me don't disrespect me
Brock don't disrespect me brah
you want to fight me why exhibits or
through the turnstile my ticket [ __ ]
hey yo where you going where you going
fight me bro why you why don't you fight
me bro fight me oh [ __ ] yo chat he seems
to me I'm not a fish I swear to it
oh god that's perverted that's fine
where did I go I got this [ __ ] game
man lines are for people I'm a pet
octopus damn it why is life so hard yeah
why all I want to do is octave shut up
[ __ ] shut up
don't disrespect me woman I'll hug you
I'll hug you
that's my ticket thank you thank you
thank you thanks guys hope you're happy
yeah
I don't know what's going on either I
really don't love making is a
complicated thing for sssomething
so why am i the only fish that has
escaped there has to be other fishes
right
no sorry oh [ __ ] sorry man woman okay if
you're gonna be in my way then [ __ ] off
it's okay let's grab the ticket hi there
how are you you want to eat my ticket I
see you won to eat it go man you can
have a bite you want to buy it you want
to buy it you want a bite you wanna bite
come on you what you want to buy hey do
you want a bite anybody ha ha ha you
want you on what do hi guys oh god how
the hell am I gonna go through there
fish don't walk like that you've got to
hunt your back more I could be a
ballerina baby do you like this baby
do you like that watch me go through
baby I got this no problem oh yeah sorry
the tickets so fast
soon I'll need a bigger camera when are
you gonna tell me something I care about
gosh you're boring me woman just kidding
I love you I'm a fish I have different
interests okay I like soul and I could
just climb over it oh god this is not
good for my reputation man really a king
really this is my worst nightmare
why who invented this this is not humane
okay I got it I did it I somehow did it
okay I got a sneak past got a sneak past
as stealthy as possible our [ __ ] site
okay all right here we go
no problem that's the spirit my favorite
fish is Solomon okay find Stacie scarlet
and Tommy no chick I'm sorry Oh sexy
time okay by the way we're doing I
forgot what we were doing
that's right that's right watch it watch
what's happening don't look don't look
down where the hell did those a little
twice go
seriously I got a job to take care of
like yeah god no oh god no oh [ __ ] it's
one of those little [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't I
go he doesn't see me he doesn't see me
you can't see what he can't pee let's go
in here
what up [ __ ] what up [ __ ] what up
you want to play me bro bro you want to
play me bro bro bro you wanna play right
you wanna brawl you want to play me bro
flamie come on you got skill huh you
think you got skill all right yeah
that's right that's right I can't stand
if I want to
BAM it's on no I don't are you ready for
this
I called this one the octopus but get it
cuz uh che [ __ ] off you know god dammit
I can't Louis in front of my wife
she might realize I'm an octopus the key
to air hockey is just to block the goal
why are you so good at your skill that's
rap baby that's right you're my [ __ ]
now okay wait sorry let me get my prize
okay I got my crab so this can't be good
she wants to talk to us that's never a
good thing you want the prize that's so
cute you brush them off like they're
nothing like when your foot got caught
in a ceiling fan or when we ran out of
printer ink and you just made more so
what's your point
I can make ink [ __ ] be happy give six
prizes to Scarlett I'm sorry
but don't you think you're a little
someday oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
nice way to get one day I'm gonna be an
addict a debt I don't understand that
one she's looking at the crabs ass like
goddamn
that's all they could did for me yay oh
okay we're doing this one now I win a
prize
oh sorry here you go my love hey Kate
there was that time you were fixing the
sink and the disposal came on but you
wouldn't go to the hospital yet somehow
looks good as new are you ever going to
explain that well I'm really great and
shut up there we go yeah baby I'll let
it try twice tight twice what why what's
the difference between a turtle on tour
twice no one cares
the difference okay I told you it's a
present it's [ __ ] out switch here
don't you see it god dammit all right
fight me bro what I know well [ __ ] doll
[ __ ] those racists comes I just have to
score six of them ha ha ha this is the
pro way to play basketball one more baby
that's right
Michael Jordan maybe hey cake decorating
is hard man don't we play a hating
really I'm almost there
all right no dude does way okay I thank
you all right another gift for you well
I've always wondered what you keep it
the old basement but I respect your
privacy not really cuz you're asking a
lot of questions alright let's play the
last two more
oh god this will be hard seriously
ah yes how many do I need my god I was
amazing yeah I'm gonna keep this no I
can't
goddamn it so we're giving our gifts so
she would stop questioning us another
one for my lovely sorry you're usually
so talkative but when we're talking
about us you play them up babe lighten
up Eve come on babe alright last one
knock down all the targets and win hush
up oh I don't get nail it
[ __ ] nature I mean I love Nick isn't it
in unethical for me to do this oh damn
look at that [ __ ] [ __ ] nail it
gravity don't know fishes that's how you
do it like a pro
only now I'm stuck no I'm not I'm not
what are you talking about what I got
all these presents you're just hating
why don't you try to fix that instead
[ __ ] I got to do everything why do you
get old your hands are full you just
drop my gift I can't I need
I can't damn it goddamn it alright well
it looks like after dad has to save that
they saved the day again sorry sorry
let me just penetrate with my
oh [ __ ]
fishes love me all the [ __ ] love me
you don't want them anyway
I'm sorry what the hell there we go ah
god damn it I'm trying this is the worst
day of my life okay we almost got it Oh
who's head of security here seriously
okay I feel like having a real decision
by 8:00 sharp
she's going to the shark tank for some
work to do she's cheating on baby sharks
god damn it
all right that about does it for episode
four
hope you brothers enjoyed watching leave
a like if it did this game is amazing
hit this guy convert AIC brothers with a
new one tomorrow
lemme res
Oh [ __ ] get out the way get out the way
[ __ ] get out the way